the ritual that has survived much better
and that still contains the meaning of a
central initiation mystery for the
devout is the Catholic practice of the
elevation of the chalice it has been
described by dr. young and his
transformation symbolism in the mass the
lifting up of the chalice in the air
prepares the spiritualization of the
wine this is confirmed by the invocation
to the Holy Ghost that immediately
follows the invocation serves to infuse
the wine with holy spirit for it is the
Holy Ghost who begets fulfills and
transforms after the elevation the
chalice was in former times set down to
the right of the host to correspond with
the blood that flowed from the right
side of Christ the ritual of communion
is everywhere the same whether it is
expressed by drinking of the cup of
Dionysus or of the holy Christian
chalice but the level of awareness each
brings to the individual participant is
different the Dionysiac participant
looks back to the origin of things to
the storm birth of the God who is
blasted from the resistant womb of
Mother Earth in the frescoes of the
villa Denise daddy Infante the enacted
right evoked the God as a mask of terror
reflected in the cup of Dionysus offered
by the priests to the initiate later we
find the winnowing basket with its
precious fruits of the earth and the
phallus as creative symbols of the gods
manifestation as the principle of
breeding and growth in contrast to this
backward look with its central focus on
nature's eternal cycle of birth and
death the Christian mystery points
forward to the initiates ultimate hope
of union with a transcendent God Mother
Nature with all her beautiful seasonal
changes has been left behind and the
central figure of Christianity offers
spiritual certainty for he is the son of
God in heaven yet the to somehow fuse in
the figure of Orpheus the God who
remembers Dionysus but looks forward to
Christ